okay you won't believe this everyone so
we came early to the restaurant to visit
you to celebrate the big one year
there's already a line outside let's go
out and meet your friends enjoy lunch
yes if you're not happy with it send it
back
okay one year anniversary how does it
feel
thank us for me many ways is almost like
a second home we have five businesses
here now it was a dream we opened up the
books with 30,000 reservations I think
it's one of the fourth or fifth highest
grossing restaurants now in America all
that is gordon turned up the heat on
Kelty and me we faced off in our very
own Hell's Kitchen on the Vegas strip
YouTube welcome to my Wells okay it's a
little hot back here as well the
challenge pan seared scallops in just
three minutes
are we ready your three minutes start
now okay I'm ready for IDing the oil and
I'll catch the oil first goodness sake
too much oil my gosh it's a nonstick pan
that's why I called nonstick jeez
Todd 60 seconds gone how many scholars
you go in the pan
I got signal-d seven olives get one out
if you think that rattled me you'd be
right cut in there you say on please
don't ceiling cold oh my god it's coming
it's coming it's coming it's 45 seconds
to go use a spoon lady use a spoon of
course it's hot kitchen in the end there
can only be one winner the most
outstanding scholar dish that the one
that with serving our restaurants
congratulations Kevin
it's not you calculation take your apron
off your time is done in Hell's Kitchen
[Music]